most marketing plans will start with a
lot of what we learned in Lesson one
like who's your audience who are their
personas or what segments are you going
to focus on you'll consider your
competitive analysis and your value
proposition so now that we've identified
our marketing goals we can focus on
creating our distribution plan the
distribution plan will focus on how and
where we're going to reach our potential
customers now of course we're not trying
to make a full marketing plan that the
chief marketing officer at a fortune 500
company might make but we try to focus
on the most effective parts of the plan
that will help you figure out your
action plan to take your product to
market but first we need to do some
research there are a few tools and
different options we'll go over to help
you conduct market research the goal is
to look for insights that'll allow us to
select some starting points not to come
up with a super elaborate plan remember
marketing is all about making a
hypothesis testing the market and then
adjusting be sure to write down your
hypothesis and results so that you learn
what worked and what didn't work now
we're going to go ahead and use
abarkment as our research example when
we talk about different tools I
encourage you to follow along with your
own app or feel free to follow along
with the bargman if you don't have one
yet